[Música]
y hablamos de salud en directo américa
de france 24 ya está conmigo en el
estudio más romeros a la mar bienvenida
muy buenos días feliz martes para
ustedes vamos a empezar hablando
entonces los tratamientos como le
adelantábamos en el sumario de kobe 19
que avances hubo en estos medicamentos
que se desarrollan para luchar contra la
pandemia mar buenos dias raúl pues si
ayer nos despertamos ya con la noticia
de que merck había solicitado que la
agencia del medicamento de eeuu la fd
apruebe su medicamento el bolo pyramid
contra el kobe 19 este medicamento
reduciría en un 50% las
hospitalizaciones o las muertes sea
decir los casos de kobe grave en
pacientes contagiados de escuchemos lo
que dijo la compañía
el impacto extraordinario de esta
pandemia requiere que nos movamos con
una urgencia sin precedentes y esto es
lo que nuestro equipo ha hecho al
presentar esta solicitud a la fed para
el monu pyramid a los 10 días de recoger
los datos ahora mismo recordemos raúl
que esta pastilla de merck es la única
que está en una fase tan avanzada para
tratar el commit 19 pero no es el único
tratamiento que existe más allá de las
vacunas repasemos hay otros tratamientos
llamados en los tratamientos de
anticuerpos monoclonales de los que ayer
también tuvimos noticias por ejemplo
salieron los datos de efectividad de uno
de los medicamentos de astrazéneca en
este sentido y también supimos que el
medicamento un medicamento similar el
regeneron va a estar siendo estudiado
para aprobarse en europa ya está
aprobado en estados unidos- estos son
tratamientos distintos a los de merck
mrk es una pastilla que lo que hace es
evitar que el virus se reproduzca en el
cuerpo de las personas contagiadas
mientras que los tratamientos de
anticuerpos se inyectan anticuerpos
precisamente producidos en masa en los
laboratorios para ayudar a nuestro
sistema inmune a combatir la enfermedad
hay varios que existen aquí están viendo
algunos de los ejemplos
con las cifras que sabemos de sus
efectividad es por ejemplo vemos que el
regeneron tiene alrededor de un 70% de
efectividad a la hora de prever las
infecciones asintomáticas es decir los
síntomas de kobe 19 una vez uno ya se ha
contagiado y las de astrazéneca que
fueron precisamente las que las que se
publicaron ayer sabemos también que
prevé previenen un 50 por ciento más o
menos la mitad de los casos de covite
graves es decir bueno son noticias que
tenemos que seguir con muchísima
atención raúl porque probablemente van a
hacer una diferencia enorme en la lucha
contra la pandemia así es marc y
seguimos hablando de la pandemia y vamos
a obrar con la situación de rusia que
hace días viene en aumento toda la cifra
de muertos de contagios que está pasando
en esta nación mar que sabemos es una
situación alarmante ya son siete días
consecutivos con más de 900 muertes al
día por 19 precisamente en las últimas
24 horas son 973 es la cifra más alta en
toda la pandemia registrada en el país
repasemos la situación epidemiológica de
rusia en ahí en el país ahora es
prácticamente el que tiene más muertes
con respecto a su población en todo el
mundo 63 muertes por millón de
habitantes desde las cifras más altas
que encontramos ahora mismo globalmente
repasemos aproximadamente el 30 por
ciento de la población ha recibido la
pauta completa de vacunación eso es una
estadística que está por ejemplo por
debajo de muchos países de américa
latina' de colombia de brasil de
argentina por ejemplo para que nos
hagamos una idea comparativa más o menos
y recordemos que no es por falta de
disponibilidad de vacunas rusia
desarrolló su propia vacuna a la de
sputnik entonces básicamente lo que está
pasando es que no hay una confianza de
la población en esos fármacos y por eso
hay una cifra tan baja de personas
inmunizadas en este país así es marc
ahora vamos a con el llamado de
organizaciones de la salud en defensa
del clima cuáles son las alertas que
lanzan ellos para el futuro un tema muy
importante que esperamos desarrollar
también en futuros espacios de salud
pero bueno por ahora expliquemos estos
son centenares de organizaciones
internacionales que agrupan unos cuatro
unos 45 millones de trabajadores de la
salud que en conjunto con la
organización mundial de la salud
hicieron un llamado a los gobiernos
frente a la cob 26 que se celebrará de
aquí poco escuchemos lo que ms
sabemos muy bien que el cambio climático
está afectando los pilares de nuestra
salud la comida el agua la calidad del
aire el refugio como podéis imaginar
todo esto representará un gran riesgo
para nuestra salud por lo tanto debemos
invertir en adaptarnos al cambio
climático en tener instalaciones y
sistemas de salud más resilientes y una
sociedad más resiliente versions site y
básicamente lo que piden raúl son una
serie de medidas para evitar el cambio
climático no principalmente que evitar
que aumente todavía más la temperatura
por encima del 1,5 grados centímetros
terminar definitivamente con los
combustibles fósiles y que los países
ricos hagan un mayor esfuerzo en
compensar los efectos del cambio
climático en los países de ingresos
bajos que van a ser quienes van a sufrir
las peores consecuencias la alerta es
alta repasemos las cifras de los efectos
del cambio climático sobre la salud se
prevee según cifras de la organización
mundial de la salud que el cambio
climático provoque 250 mil muertes
anuales entre 2030 y 2050 pero no sólo
tenemos que alarmaron futuro también en
el presente ya por ejemplo la
contaminación del aire provoca 7
millones anuales de muertes prematuras
de esos raúl es aproximadamente una
muerte cada 13 minutos en todo el mundo
terrible lo que está contando da miedo
no para dónde va el mundo de buenas
noticias que todavía hay tiempo para
cambiarlo y esperemos que pues lo
cambiemos pronto y el cambio está en
nosotros
marc muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud nos vemos mañana
con más de esta sección